みなさんこんにちは。国際未来教育機関の田川と申します。
研究における生成AIの活用法、その第1回へようこそお越しいただきました。
これから第8回まで、2ターン分ですかね、の授業ですけども、どうぞよろしくお願いいたします。
それでは、この授業でどのようなことを学ぶか見ていこうと思います。
この授業の狙いです。それは、研究活動の中で生成AIを倫理的かつ適切に使えるようになることです。
多様な皆様がこの授業を受講していると思います。
研究者を目指している方も、高度な専門職を目指している方もいらっしゃるでしょう。
しかし、様々な将来のキャリアにおいて、生成AIというのが無視できない存在になりつつあります。
その第一歩として、使い方の作法を持ってほしいというのがこの動画となります。
鍵になる問いはこれです。
AIを研究で使おうといったとき、あなたの判断基準、つまりクライテリアは何でしょうか。
そして、それを他の方に説明できるでしょうか。
分野によってもですね、今回の話題、このAIを使えるかどうかというのが大きく異なります。
だからこそ、迷ったときにも立ち返れる考え方の基準を持つこと、これがこの授業の中学となります。
授業の目標をですね、もう少し具体的な達成目標に書き分けたのがこちらです。
知識、理解としては、研究倫理、学術情報流通、生成AIの利活用リテラシーと仕組みを外観することで、自分の言葉で説明できることでございます。
応用分析としては、各分野の学会、あるいはですね、投稿する雑誌における生成AIの需要状況を調べまして、気をつけるべき観点を指摘できるということです。
そして、事例、先行研究におけるAI活用の事例や手法を比較して、ご自身の分野での影響を分析できるようになりましょうということです。
それから、評価、授業の内容として、異分野の仲間との共同を通じて、学び方そのもの、AIをどうやって学んでいくか、あるいは研究で活かしていくかということを語るようになったり、
最終的に、皆さんご自身が研究でAIとどう関わるかを言葉として、つまり意見を持って説明できるということを目指していきたいと思います。
第1回は、この一番手前にあります共通の土台を作る会でございます。
8回の構成について見ておきましょう。
第1回が今回の、生成AIと倫理、並びにリテラシーの会となります。
第2回目が、学術療法流通、つまり論文や作読といった成果交付の仕組みです。
第3回が、生成AIの仕組みで、これは実際に皆さんのお手元で、AIのミニチュア、生成AIのミニチュアを使っていただく演習を行っていこうと思います。
ここまでがですね、比較的基本的な内容で、オンデマンドが中心となります。
次に、第4回、第5回が、研究、論文といった領域において、AIやアカデミックインテグリティ、並びにですね、各分野における活用の状況といったものを扱います。
その上で、第6回、第7回でですね、先行研究でAIがどのように使われているかなどを分析しまして、研究で実際に使われている方法を学びます。
そして第8回が、議論とリフレクションとなっていまして、最終レポートの提出とつながります。
このようにですね、オンデマンドだったり、グループワークだったり、様々な形式で進行してまいりますので、この点、シラバスをよく読んで進めていただければと思います。
受講の仕方についても説明しておきます。
基本の形はですね、オンデマンドで、先に情報について全部見ておいてください。
第2ターム、第3タームと、結構長めの回となっていますが、あくまでこのナレッジパートはですね、早めに見ておくと良いと思います。
また、対面、同時双方向といったところのこの授業の前までですね、視聴いただきたいのと、できれば順番通り見ていただくとありがたいかなと思います。
その次は、同時双方向と対面におけるですね、グループワークとなります。
最後、調査、議論、レポートみたいなところをですね、繰り返していきますので、その点、様々なワークがあります。
予習・復習において、AIの利用は大いに結構です。
課題においてですね、必要に応じて私の方で、ここまではAIを使っていいよということは明示していきますので、その点はよろしくお願いします。
また、どこでAIを使ったかといったところは必ず申告なさるようにお願いいたします。
このナレッジセッションというのは、あくまで考えていくための前提を通知するものです。
皆さんの分野における答えというものがありますので、それは対面の授業で一緒に作っていきましょう。
さて、先ほどワークが2つあると言いましたが、このように近接のグループで行うもの、つまり研究理論の観点の調査は、近いグループにおいて分けさせていただきます。
それからですね、AIがどのように研究で活用されているかといったところはですね、これは逆にいろんな分野の人を混ぜて、複数分野において実行させていただきます。
最後のレポートは各個人での実施となります。
まずですね、ちょっと課題といったらなんですが、皆さんの研究分野、並びにこの授業への関心をですね、含む自己紹介をMoodleの方に記入いただければありがたいかなと思います。
そして、今回のこの第1回は10本の動画で講座されています。
1番は学び方、並びにこの授業全体の話ですね。
こちらはこの動画となっておりまして、その次にですね、AIを知るということでですね、
倫理であったり仕組み、限界について簡単に見ていきます。
それぞれの内容は、例えば仕組みであれば第3回の方に詳しくありますし、倫理についてはですね、ワークの1つ目で詳しく使うことになるでしょう。
それから研究倫理のパートがありまして、最後にですね、これからAIは研究にどのような影響を与えているかということをご説明できればと思います。
最後ですね、これ最後のワーク、第8回の課題にもかかってきますが、
僕自身がどんな基準を持っているかといったことについてご説明できればと思います。
なので、この第1回は授業の全体を理解する10個の動画で構成されております。
こちら、私の自己紹介ですので、もし関心があれば、ぜひ眺めてみてください。
僕自身はですね、地球学生科学で研究所をやっているんですけども、今も時々研究しているんですが、非常にですね、幅広い分野の手法を学ぶ必要がありまして、
さらにですね、プログラミングなどのこともございました。
そうした中で、非常に骨が折れていたんですけども、生成をうまく活用することによって、もっと先まで研究ができるなというような可能性を感じるということでございます。
僕自身もですね、AIにおいていろいろ悩んでいるという感じですけども、一緒にですね、AIをかける研究というものをこの授業で考えて、切り開いていければと思います。
それでは短い期間ですが、どうぞよろしくお願いいたします。